canada is still considering its role in
all of this and what our military is
capable of offering families of
diplomats at the embassy in ukraine and
military personnel have now been ordered
out of the country our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson is looking at
that angle tonight mercedes
donna canada now says that diplomats
families must leave ukraine due to the
ongoing military buildup and what the
minister's office described as quote
destabilizing activities in and around
ukraine this follows the lead of the
united states which ordered diplomats
families to leave the u.s embassy in
kiev on sunday prime minister justin
trudeau and his cabinet are still
deliberating over what next steps they
might take to help ukraine he's expected
to make an announcement here tomorrow in
ottawa on that national security sources
say they expect ottawa and the liberal
government to approve a shipment of
hundreds of guns and ammunition for the
ukrainian military it is unclear though
if ottawa is considering ukraine's
request for more troops on operation
unifier in ukraine the government could
also choose to put more troops into the
region around ukraine by beefing up
operation reassurance which is based in
latvia and the mediterranean sea but it
could expand back out to countries like
romania where we've had a presence
before
sources say that canada is not looking
to fight a war and does not believe the
small contribution of guns and ammo to
the ukrainian military is going to make
any kind of a strategic difference but
this donna really is about a signal of
support and showing nato wide deterrence
something allies are collaborating on
the canadian government is also bracing
for the potential of more cyber attacks
from russia according to national
security sources when those additional
supports for ukraine are announced in
the coming days another potential
trigger a planned visit for the minister
of national defense anita anand to
ukraine
that certainly they think could trigger
more cyber attacks on canada donna
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks canada has the largest ukrainian
population outside of ukraine and russia
more than 1.3 million people identify as
ukrainian-canadian and many are
increasingly uneasy about the
uncertainty in their homeland mike drale
has been speaking to some of them
even in 2016 when maxon solya rescue had
a family reunion in kyuv he couldn't
escape the feeling that russia was at
the doorstep
tensions have been simmering he says
every day since ukraine's pro-russian
government was ousted in 2014. we've
been
uh living under a pressure and under
stress for for quite uh for quite a
while now but definitely the last months
or so
i think that level of anxiety
increased tenfold russia is all
ukrainian canadians are talking about
right now toronto's christine
eliaszewski who lives off and on in
ukraine says the uncertainty has left
many ill at ease i'm not scared
i'm not scared but i am very very
anxious
i'm worried i don't know what's going to
happen and nobody knows what's going to
happen canada has a large ukrainian
population 1.4 million based on the last
census mostly in western canada and the
prairies they've been vocal in their
attempts to encourage western
governments to intervene on their behalf
but while the number of politicians who
have posted pictures with the hashtag
stand with ukraine banner creates
conversation words and pictures will
only do so much
we believe that the most effective way
to deter for the russian invasion is to
take proactive rather than reactive
steps
ukrainians are not asking anyone to
fight for them but they need our help to
defend their country against a colonial
power seeking their destruction russian
president vladimir putin has been very
clear in recent years that he believes
ukraine is fundamentally part of russia
even going so far as to call russians
and ukrainians one people he won't go
away and i think ukrainians will be
faced with uh with putin for the and
russia for the rest of their lives for
the rest of the
history until the regime changes in
russia that could make for a very cold
future
microlight global news toronto